bring about lasting peace in countries
better forgotten likes Nelson man and
again to your point which is it's
important to remember at some point
there has to be justice as well it's a
very important piece of this but when
your house is on fire first you gotta
put the fire out and so right now we're
just trying to get the this element the
atrocities themselves to stop to stop
being funded then then the next step is
to bring these people to justice and
that's that's a another step but first
and foremost we're trying to put the
fire out Henry Ridgwell from Voice of
America news Perhaps it's an attempt to
answer your your question mr.
prenderghast about why can't we use
those tools that we used in the Iran
nuclear deal and since well we're
sitting in a city now that groups like
transparency international suggest that
100 billion dollars is routed through
here and corrupt money every year and
that's because of the unique combination
of lawyers and bankers and everything
else that goes on here it was in the
interests of the British government
geopolitically to get that Iran deal
done and to work on those sanctions
since isn't the truth to it that you're
relying on the conscience of the British
government and not its geopolitical
interest and there lies the problem
because when you're dealing with Chinese
state industries and and other partners
that the British government also trades
on trade with they're not going to take
those risks they're not going to put
that pressure on that they would have
done with the Iran deal for example that
you use so you're relying on the
conscience of the British government and
that that isn't the bottom line for them
it's it's it's not the financial that
this city this country relies on open
laws to an extent that it
plays up well quick quest answer to that
and if you want to add anything George
um you know first of all remarkably
frankly we've found allies in the US
government and UK government and within
the European Union system in countries
in governments all over the world people
who join public service because they
believe in making a little better and
yes there is no question the premise is
absolutely accurate that Iran matters
more than North Korea and then then
South Sudan on the on the mattering map
of strategic interests but when you have
less top-heavy interests like with
respect to Iran you have incredible
micromanagement from the top over every
detail of what policies are made on
something like South Sudan there are
caring conscientious well motivated
public officials who are able to run
with policy initiatives with the support
of their superiors and try to make a
difference and so we rely on those kinds
of alliances and in order to move the
ball forward on policy secondly you have
all these policy tools like unexplained
wealth orders and what's the other one
in the UK that have that what's that
it's something as if freezing orders who
you know where they're looking for
successes you know and let's show let's
demonstrate that these policy tools can
be effective now are they going to go
after someone with billions and billions
of dollars invest in the UK realistic
well there's all kinds of political
calculations they have to make but if we
can say well here's here are some houses
here's some accounts with these folks
from this country which as you just said
it isn't maybe as important to some of
these other places why don't you take
action on these you actually get some
traction so it's it cuts both ways yeah
we'd love to have the
of attention and interest that
policymakers focus on for North Korean
for Iran and Syria but we don't so we
look for allies and we look for ways to
provide success stories to those
governments to take action with the
policy tools these militant policy tools
that they have at their disposal make an
impact to be able to make a difference
in these places thank you guys yeah
there's no press here